[Music]
so mgk what's up with him stabbing
himself what an idiot
that's love dude
let's hear it in his words please tell
me he explains it yes
this is also like right when i started
was was was starting to date you know
megan and and i like
i was holding it together it was just it
was a bad night like the whole like we i
won the ping pong match i went home
i was like i had this travis got me this
uh he got me a knife that was uh that
had an engravement from the new album on
it and i was like oh check this out this
is sick and i threw it up and it came
and stuck in my hand you see that right
here i do see that yeah that was from
when a knife stuck in my cause you know
how you throw it up and you're supposed
to catch it i looked at her i was like
check this out
and i was like
she's like
she's like you are the coolest dude i've
ever lived
and then the next morning as soon as she
left i was like
yo i need stitches real quick yeah i
like dude i got a bruised coccyx over
here and a knife
and a knife in my hand
dude that's so
you
waited till the next morning
that's kind of tough yeah that is kind
of that's pretty hard yeah
that's hard as [ __ ]
you know
people can be cringe and do something
tough yeah yeah you can be cringe but
that's hard as [ __ ] just
you're just resting it like [ __ ]
sword in the stone
sword in the skin oh like he didn't take
it out till the next morning i don't
know he slept with that [ __ ] in he's
just like if i don't remove it it won't
bleed
looks pretty ill right yeah
the passion is actually when you take it
out that's the danger that's why he said
that [ __ ] up ass sentence
he's like passing out from the wound
yeah she's like do you smoke weed i am
weak
[Laughter]
oh my god are you okay
this isn't the first time i've stabbed
myself
all right because i am weed because i'm
weed
dang i hate i hate that i hate talk
shows
like that's not a good story
but i saw like nine headlines about that
probably from [ __ ] his pr team mm-hmm
you know what i mean
and then when his book comes out
did you read the will smith book
no i didn't did you no but i'm thinking
about buying and reading all like the
brutal [ __ ] in there yeah
just cause like yeah
what else is in there because that's
those are like the singles you know yeah
what's the [ __ ] full album sound like
um
[Music]
you know
you're saying you got got by the pr team
a little bit like i want to know like
what if i read some crazy ass [ __ ] in
there yeah what could be crazier i don't
know but i want to be
you know
i feel like i would just read that and
will be like i did six months in
some country bleaching [ __ ] i'd be
like okay
he's like i'll save that for the next
book yeah
i can damn it
um let's go through this metaverse [ __ ]
okay so somebody bought a yacht in the
metaverse
we know people are buying land someone
said [ __ ] it
yeah i looked up some of those land
prices they were insane
yeah yeah i know some of it's nuts
someone paid 650 000 for a non-existent
yacht in the metaverse the yacht is
comically hideous it's actually not it's
sick in my opinion and can only be
described as minecraft-esque with its
blocky design
until the graphics get upgraded
is it is it based on
no no it looks like a lego piece yeah no
i was trying to describe it like the
color and shape and it seems like it's
based on like a lego toy
that retails for 150 bucks
yeah but you count
oh is that what that is
bro i thought it was an ebay listing
what the hell i don't know this is open
c
zoned out
that's dude i saw the funniest tweet
from some guy that was like why the [ __ ]
is everyone talking about the metaverse
he's like i just was on that [ __ ] there
was 400 people online total yeah in the
whole world no it sucks it's like no
one's actually using this show no
no this is it this is the commercial
part
yeah it just looks like a cheese grater
yeah it's white it's got two helipads
looks like it's three stories
it's got a
[ __ ] jacuzzi
dude that's the thing i think oh and
that's this yeah click that yeah hanging
out
[ __ ] yeah dude vibin is this
decentralized what is this
what is the metaverse which one is it
you know
i know there's decentraland is there
another metaverse
[Music]
who's the guy that spent 650 grand
on that
uh partner owner of tether
yeah probably
it's not a point he's just sitting there
like it's not real i'm trying to get as
much this [ __ ] as possible it's all fake
heard some dude in the metaverse having
a mid-life crisis still yeah god i
[ __ ] should buy a boat
i should i'm gonna buy it yeah and he's
telling his wife no because if you're
riding in the metaverse
yeah
yeah
you don't have to deal with the
maintenance yeah exactly no it's a
one-time call well actually you do
it does break down a little bit you do
have to get it every now and then and i
do have to pay for storage and
seasonally but like we'll use it like
twice a year at least
and that's worth it you know what is
this republic realm republican yeah see
you there that's where the yacht
is from it looks like they're a part of
or they're
like decentralian is a part of republic
realm apparently
so maybe they're all connected in one
big metaverse who knows nobody knows
because nobody uses this [ __ ] yeah one
keeps talking about it but i wanted to
get a quest too and like go through it
because i want to see if it's like up to
yeah like but that's what i mean it's
like you
everything now as you hear you hear
about is like metaverse metaverse
metaverse like when's the last time you
went on the metaverse no using why did
you log onto it last never never exactly
actually using vr is like a commitment
it's you know
and
uh
it's funny like
there's all this you know
there's all these proposals about
what you can do in there and all this
chatter about it and all these people
have never used vr
like half of them are susceptible to
motion sickness
someone is going to buy this [ __ ]
metaverse jet ski for
17 eth go to use it for the first time
and vomit all over their living room oh
[ __ ] saturdays are back saturdays are
back
yeah
no they can vomit they just won't
microwave it afterwards
wait how much was that wave cruiser
oh see that's a [ __ ] steal
a thousand dollars can you buy a yacht
for 650k you can buy a jet ski for a
thousand dollars i don't know
dude that's so worth it look at that why
does it look like lego
because it's blocky no but like
we don't have to make it look like
roblox anymore like
we have the technology to do 3d
nice looking [ __ ] i think because it's
because the quests are wireless
so it's all that on-board hardware i
think it has to be shitty for it to run
decent and for everything to like load
quickly yeah i guess because the makes
sense the index you know i mean we got
it you have to you have to jack in yeah
matrix style
yeah so there's a trading shower
you got a jacket nice yeah
jacking off
get the jack in off yeah
yeah that's how you get off the
yeah jack in and jack out i have like
two brain cells today
one for jack one for off
yeah dude
you